wow you should start shoot
a boy band with all you that's called
ren sync
right hand sync it's just you're your
own backup singer yeah
hi hi hi hello
hi hi
[Music]
i hope this episode comes out near or
around christmas it sounds like it will
because uh i've got a christmas hat on
yeah it would be really dumb if this was
not
christmas and you're wearing it it would
really be i mean it wouldn't be that
dumb if it was july right
christmas in july that's a thing okay
well let's just stop janking out don't
thought this was in the way of the
camera
well i was concerned that this poll
would be in front of your face
i thank you i had the same concern
i did and i moved it christian and i sat
here for about a minute
and i was moving this thing around and
christian was like dude it's fine and i
was like
yeah but what about my face and like is
it is it on my nose
yeah he's like dude it's fine now it's
probably on my nose but you know here we
are
you can't repost that um so today in the
podcast we've got
ren weichmann yo what's up jake hey
buddy
hi the talented hey let's take a moment
and acknowledge this shirt
oh a classic still crisp from the
packaging
this is matthew 42 yep yes we've got
matthew
matt's here hand over the mantle yeah
and we've also got
a young nico yes a young straight-haired
nico
yeah wait nico yeah what's up
oh hey you want to go shoot bows
yeah actually well actually i broke it
and then i had to fix it i was really
mad about that
yeah i'm sorry wait i thought it was
your dead uncle's bow
he was also my father we have a very
complicated family yeah
yeah we'll get into that on
episodes of american tragedy so i think
the first thing to address is
holy crap jake you're not a computer
screen oh my goodness actually it is
good like seriously it feels good to be
to be back
in the uh great state of california and
uh in front of you guys
yes nice to see you man yeah uh as much
as i enjoy
speaking to you all from a microphone
and a black magic camera that i use
almost as a webcam it's better to be
here in real life sometimes
wait are you telling me that webcam
we've always seen of you has been a
black magic yeah
goodness
i was like listen i need a web camera
but i also need
a camera and i was talking with eli
uh and he's like hey you know what i use
for streaming is just the black magic
and then anytime i want to film with it
i just pop it off
and it's versatile and that's rig yeah
and it is very versatile for that i had
to get a
gotto an elgato capture card but um
it it still it works works like a charm
so use it for your brand cam
as well uh that i do not actually i use
the uh
80d for the brand cam because i can i
can
that one i just keep like ready okay
yeah on a vlog right yeah
so i can just pull that thing off and
shoot whatever i
am a big fan of not great cameras
oh yeah does that sound weird yes it
does please elaborate on what you mean
by
you're a big fan of lesser cameras
well not specifically lesser cameras i'm
a big fan of whatever camera
is easiest to use in the moment and that
high degree of image quality isn't too
important to me when it comes to the
kind of content i
generally prefer to create which is why
we've always used the canon 80d which is
a five-year-old camera at this point
for years every single one of my like
science videos was shot with that camera
even though i have regular access to a
red camera you know it's a big section
of our function
of my functional filmmaking course is
talking about that so
okay you know if you're subscribed to
the website you can find out more
information about it
that's cornerdigital.com uh an
intentional plug
seriously uh the add is good at
capturing like uh just a heightened
version of reality
um like it it's got enough uh color
and it's got enough where you can just
shoot it raw and like
make a minor adjustment to it maybe yeah
and then it's got enough dynamic range
where you can use it in
most scenarios um obviously it's a
picture camera
but it's not really most people don't
use it for that like
they usually use a different there's a
lot of different canons that people
prefer for pictures but
um yeah it's like it's really versatile
it's durable
and the nice thing before the black
magic came out but even now with the
blackmagic
the the 80d is only like a thousand
bucks
1200 bucks for the body and then if you
put a nice piece of glass on
it and you put it on a little vlog rig
it's really really handy
and the thing that it has that the
blackmagic doesn't have
is battery life um right yeah
it's got and you can add one of those
extenders to it on the bottom yeah which
we use here
yeah and that just gives you way more um
double the battery life
it does it's like it's like one of those
double mint gum commercials
with canon batteries and it does have
like a great autofocus right
yes it does have a great auto focus and
the file sizes are
fairly small nice and smooth nice love
all that it's nice to be able to like
shoot for an hour and be like oh i only
have
a couple gigabytes worth of footage as
opposed to shooting on black magic we're
like
i just filled 18 terabytes yeah what
happened
you got to check your compression there
buddy
videos that you're making so it's got
those advantages i don't want to bash
the 80d but maybe i don't know dean
and uh nick were talking and they
they're talking like they might move on
from it
i mean we've been trying to move on from
the 80d for a while now there's a moment
because it
the the camera has been dropping frames
yeah that's
rewarding and like
yeah i forgot it's camera adhd
3d hd
80d hd yeah
every time somebody says it's got adhd
[Laughter]
so with adhd and the nerf attack drone
video the nerf drone video right
that came out in march uh when jan and i
were battling up on the roof
i handedly destroyed him jan did not
stand a chance
he didn't stand a chance and uh what
other things can i say to
beat down on jan right now because he's
not here to defend him
he's lacking a finger
there's a moment after i uh i completely
obliterate him
uh and i come flying up near him and i i
don't even know what you call it i
basically just like
i modulate the throttle so
it kind of sounds like the drone's
laughing before i fly away a little
taunt
and if you actually go back and look at
that moment you can actually see it
stutters
and that is in the source footage it
wasn't the results of the
the editing or the the export or your
computer not handling that moment like
that is in the file and you can
it's like juddering at like three frames
per second for a moment was that a
random occurrence or was that based on
that was the first time i noticed it
okay and i've since noticed it in other
times and nick has also noticed it like
just
randomly maybe after like a while of
shooting maybe after the camera's heated
up
uh it just like after a while sometimes
it'll even just stop recording and turn
off
yeah it does that sometimes it's it's it
does that sometimes but
don't get me wrong i would not be
opposed to a nicer better camera
than the 80d yeah this be a canon camera
or yeah
yeah it's the canon is it the r series
yeah that's the other little
r series it's the one where we pulled
that out of the very back of my brain
yeah yeah uh there's a bunch of new ones
that are probably perhaps something we
should move to but you know
um it's one of those things where uh
it does bring on like a different image
and a different look and so you want to
consider
like all of those things uh in the
decision-making process because
like if you watch nico's functional
filmmaking episode i
literally i'm not trying to sell
functional filmmaking it's just come up
a lot because we're in the middle of
our digital producing production yeah um
and in that episode he's talking about
uh utilizing the strengths of your
camera for to suit different things like
um if you have a camera that
uh gives you the like look and feel of
the 80d
then you're not necessarily going to
want to use that in like a a situation
where you have low light or you need
high dynamic range in order to like
capture things like that um and so
that decision making has to go into
every time you every time you buy and
use a camera
you can't just it's not one size fits
all
what's going on out there nico just put
on the vr headset and now i'm getting
extreme fomo in here
look at me put on the headset and walk
away oh that's a taunt right there
yeah no ren i think you've checked off
all the boxes so you talked about drones
you've appealed to that next podcast
we're going to talk one wheels with nico
let's talk about how this okay oh wait
you got i totally asked my train of
thought
cool yeah that's our podcast
one important thing for me for cameras
is quick boot up time and i don't know
how long like the sony cameras take to
boot up i know uh
all of the crew cuts episodes are shot
on the sony a7s
iii i believe which daniel's been
shooting and editing with yeah um i
don't know how quickly that thing boots
up but i know some of the other cameras
take a little while to like kind of turn
on yeah like i just want to record this
real quick
that's why i love the gopro so much you
hit a button and about three seconds
later it's rolling
from being turned off to rolling black
magics take a a little bit
they're pretty quick but the 80ds are
quicker gopro's obviously really fast
um so that's also something to consider
i don't know how people shoot vlogs on
like red
epics and stuff like that yeah i've seen
or the komodos they're starting to shoot
on the komodo since they're actually
small
it's just necessary it's like first of
all yeah very unnecessary for internet
content but also like
yeah the boot up time on that it's not
it's not even close
it takes a while at this moment yeah
what's up cut
like you're like hold on let me get this
moment cut five minutes later
right now can we just pause this for one
second i am a big fan of the komoda
though oh it's a great camera that's a
pretty first that's the little baby
block of cheese one right yeah
yeah jan's got the the white one it's
crazy it's
smaller than you even think like when
you see it in pictures or you know when
people are operating it like it looks
small but when you're actually holding
it in your hands
it's like it's insane that they put that
much camera into
that texture act yeah it's like yeah
seriously
yeah it holds all the power yeah how is
it picture-wise compared to the other
reds
uh it's very complicated very good yeah
yeah it's a red camera it's a good red
one
yeah yeah yeah you shoot 6k yeah i
believe so
yeah i think you can sign off on that i
haven't
we used it on the commercial production
yeah and i think that was a 6k
yeah you were shooting with it oh that
was jam it was all jammed
on ronin while one wheeling yeah that
was his baby yeah he owns that camera so
nice yeah uh so hey i want to talk about
a connection here
this shirt maybe if you guys are new to
the corridor cast
and to quarter digital in general you
know g lord yeah you might not know what
this
shirt is um you may not have seen young
nico over here
he's actually been around it's actually
my rapper name
i was also thinking sorry there's that
rapper six nine yeah and i'm five nine
so i was thinking
i you should make my rapper name five
nine oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay all right so be honest
you interned with us in 2016
right i don't have to look at my watch
it just helps me
oh yeah it was four years ago yeah yeah
2016
april 2016. yeah mm-hmm i remember
getting that first email like it was
yesterday
i like i jumped into the air i would
have hit the ceiling
so uh one of the fans uh made
a design yeah drew lehman because
in uh in the uh lore of the sam and nico
vlogs
salmon eagle the salmon eagle vlogs
we were killing you multiple times and
uh yeah
i don't know how that started i think it
was a carmichael thing it started
between you me and carmichael it just
like
it was it was when i shot you in the
chest with an arrow because it was
like the first time in the vlogs the
vlogs were very young at that point just
a few months old
uh and we're like i forget we didn't
know what we were doing at the time it's
like a one-off joke it was just a
one-off joke yeah
and ever it was the first time that we'd
actually done a visual effect in one of
the vlogs
for the vlog and it had taken everyone
by complete surprise and it was just
good enough that like you couldn't tell
that it was fake and
everyone's just like wait what my
parents when they watched it were like
and then we just like drag you off
screen and that was the end of the video
sorry i keep hitting your mic it's okay
i knew it would happen i knew it would
happen
um that are just like really dirty on
the back side from getting dragged so
many times
and then yeah i guess we just kind of
kept building on that like the next
episode uh
got hit by a car yeah he trapped in a we
locked you in a plastic
cube yeah and it just it was one of
those like little
dumb long-running jokes that we just
kept kind of building on until it kind
of became this thing the audience was
like really attached to it yeah
and next thing we know like this is like
42 is the ultimate one
i i it was one of those improv moments
that i was like
what number is the perfect 42 i was like
or not the perfect peter i was like 42.
did that come from what's that book
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy yeah
i'm sure it did
i i plucked the first number i thought
it was in my head 42 it's the most
important number in the universe
yeah the answer to like all life and
happiness or something like that i am
butchering that
he did so yeah then
drew made the design and then he sent us
the design
i think it was just a drawing originally
but then we took a picture of it and we
put it on like twitter
or something it's a sick design and we
were like hey should we make this into a
shirt and
everyone resoundingly said hell yes
so that's exactly what we did and i
haven't seen this shirt
in since april 10th 2016.
[Laughter]
yours is in like pristine condition do
you want to know why
yes because i don't think i've ever worn
it oh i think i
think i've worn it once because it was
washed and it was sitting in my drawer
at the bottom
it looks washed i'm like the the
texturing off yeah looks washed
but i'm pretty sure i only wore it once
this is the first time i've worn it in
probably like two years why'd you only
wear it once
because i don't like you
to the point sure so
we used to go direct to garment on these
uh which is like a printing process
that's
super fast but also the printing quality
is a little bit
subpar to like true
um screen printing is that like iron-on
stuff
no it's above iron-on okay yeah iron-on
is like above iron yeah
it's like two or three steps above iron
okay but it's one of those things where
it's like if i was to put this through
the wash maybe a dozen times
it would look completely different yeah
way more faded maybe parts would be like
completely gone
and so thank you to everyone out there
who bought a shirt back in the day
because that was that got us
to actually go to a proper manufacturer
eventually um i remember when we were
starting like
i mean you were there right when we
started the like merchant
furnace the first run of shirts where it
was like
on the other side of the hole yeah oh
yeah and i went around to all these
different printers around
la because you know we're real close to
like the garment district and so i
figured oh i'll go local
and i'll find and they all had minimum
orders which
you know like even a hundred minimum
order at that time was a ton for us you
know i was thinking like 10.
and so at that point like you got it you
got to go to somebody who's gonna like
pay you're going to pay full price
basically you're going to play like next
to consumer price for that
and so eventually we started going
direct to garment because we could
actually like make a little bit of money
on it
even though we still for the first like
three years we did merch we didn't make
any money on it at all
um but then uh yeah and then the peter
42 design came along and
and revenue just skyrocketed yeah and
basically yeah
once i mean he's yeah you got it right
there you got the face of money
yeah look at this look at that he's got
moxie yeah
look at that i do specifically remember
sam being incredibly excited about this
shirt yeah this design on a shirt sam
that's surprising he was like kind of
like the one who was like we
got to do this specifically about this
design okay i haven't since sam's not in
the room
i'd like to take this i'd like to take
this what's the strangest
or most hilarious encounter you've ever
had with him
we don't have enough time in this
podcast
because i like it took me
like two maybe like a year or two years
really to like really be comfortable
sitting in a room with sam
because he's such a and i don't think
that negatively i just mean like he's
such a
um the way that his brain works is like
you know
a little bit different than other people
and what are you trying to say
i don't think i'm there yet okay i think
i got another year to go yeah i find
myself i'm usually way more comfortable
with sam when it's just him and i like
sitting in a car
okay i don't know i remember he used to
drive this uh
this blue ford tour was it a tourist it
was like a hatchback fiesta yeah
something like the dubstep guns car
yeah and he he had this oh yeah he had
the dubstep gun's car and then he got
another one that was like a modern
version of the dubstep
puns car he just got rid of that one
yeah yeah i was about to say that but i
realized you're talking about the older
older
yeah the old the original one yeah and
he used to have this uh
character in there like a rat finkle
character that used to hang from the
window
what is a rat finkle it's like a
character it's like a cartoon character
on
what i i wish i wish we had the monitor
here because we could look it up
yeah it's basically it's a character
what's this ratfinkle what what the hell
does a rat finger look like my algorithm
is gonna love this
but i just remember it used to hang from
sam's mirror as like some what just
oh okay it's it drives like the
freaking yeah i recognize
that head silhouette yeah it's like it's
like a punk thing i don't know
and so i don't even know where it's from
or where it came from but i just
remember that thing he said hang in
sam's car and i just remember being on
these car rides with sam
and like seeing rat finkel just swinging
and like him and i was sitting there so
like oh so
how about this how about the shooting
location yeah
yeah cool uh-huh and that was like for a
year that was our relationship
did you know sam in high school i kind
of like vaguely like he was like one of
the guys in your school you're like i
know you by
visual so he uh i knew nico because we
were on the same cross-country ski team
and then we had our friend david lovett
who helped write the book
right so i was i was in like youth
groups with david and him and i were
pretty good friends
because he was he was friends with one
of my best friends and so david would
i was friends with david and then uh we
used to go to
uh like halo lan parties and the first
time
i remember sam from school but like the
first time i met him
yeah actually yeah uh we got this one on
sale right now actually it's it's the
halo gun it's the thing
it's not clear at all that it's from
halo but it's cool you can tell if you
just i mean
you can have six magnum manufactured by
misra arms yes so i figured people
that'll get it will get it
sure and people that don't won't i've
read i i used to be able to say i've
read every single halo book but then
they just kept coming out and then i
oh yeah that's hard to they've also got
i stopped after like a dozen they got
more and more ridiculous too
yeah kind of started falling off the
bandwagon when they started going 100
000 years ago
yeah that's true 100 000 years ago
how do you keep track of all those
timelines anyway i totally interrupted
you oh no i mean
you would go to halo land parties which
are still in my opinion some of the most
precious
like memories you could possibly i
remember sam being on i was pretty good
okay i was pretty good because we used
to play a lot
and uh i just remember him being on one
of the other teams
just slaughtering me every time and
being like god damn it
that was my first memory of sam right
there slaughtering
video games yeah yeah wow not much has
changed
no no clearly not i just don't play
anymore i'm like
i'm good on that i got halo 2 friends
again i love it
that's so much fun the master chief
collection yeah i got some
guys that i will play with and just like
from back in the day we used to play
like oh damn like reunion friends oh
reunion yeah those are high school
buds yeah yeah yeah dang yeah and we we
still like
we're still the same same stupid banter
and dude was it uh
november 9th 2004 that was a release
date
two i was three years old
[Laughter]
you were three years you were no i was
six
yeah god dang it it was close enough
that i believed you without question
you were still playing emirates right in
your diapers
no i was playing nanasaur anybody know
that game nanasaur
no dude what is that let's change the
topics
nanostore is not a good rabbit hole to
go down apparently is
the best okay i'm sorry check out check
out that game
i do love that the halo games have couch
co-op which i feel like not many games
have now
and they've been trying to pull away
from that a little bit because the games
are so like render intensive that they
can't
actually render simultaneous viewpoints
yeah at the same time
yeah so i think it was like halo 5
didn't have like four player co-op it
had
two-person co-op i believe and they were
like wanting to get rid of that too and
it's like well you still have
multiplayer it's like that's not the
same
yeah yeah that was uh that was a time i
think
um it's a time to be alive man it was a
time to be alive you know
one of those times yeah ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls it's the time
in the episode where i tell you about
today's sponsor
storyblocks now if you don't know
storyblocks is the one
stop shop say it with me one stop shop
for
all your stock asset needs okay they've
got everything from high quality
4k b-roll templates that you can use for
after effects and motion graphics to
audio assets and sound assets and more
they are the best place where corridor
digital constantly is getting
all of the stock assets that we need for
the videos that we make and there's a
couple reasons
why we choose to use storyblocks they
have a virtually unlimited library
that's constantly being updated and
refreshed meaning that every time you go
to check for a stock asset there's gonna
be new stuff on the site with their
unlimited all-access plan
we can download as much from the site
and use it whenever we want
however we want in any types of projects
that we want now
let me tell you why that's important
because it's all royalty free
if you're using something from
storyblocks and you put it in a
commercial project or you put it in a
project for a client or it's just for
your own personal video it doesn't
matter it's all the same
you can download it and use it however
you want if you guys are
just starting out making youtube videos
or you're already
well along in your career as a creator
consider storyblocks as another tool in
your toolkit to help you
effectively do what you need to do to
get your videos done
i can't tell you how many times we just
need a little bit of b-roll
or the right sound effect and instead of
having to spend hours and hours and
hours
either going out and getting it
ourselves we just download it
plug it in and use it freely it's pretty
remarkable it's a really special service
and i don't think
many people appreciate it unless you
really run into this problem as a
creator don't miss your time don't waste
my time just head on over to
storybox.comcast and get started that's
storyblocks.comcast so thanks for
listening thank you for this wonderful
episode break and now
back to the podcast uh anyways let's
talk about time right now
um what's going on right now boys you
guys have just been learning
unreal events i've yet to learn unreal
i've yet to start digging into that but
i intend to
i want to make a vr game ren i need your
help with some math later
okay what are you struggling with i'm
trying to
like okay so we got these little dean
i'm making this like shooter game where
you play as clint and you're running
around but he has
it's like in the post-apocalyptic future
where he's eating only
uh freeze-dried cheeseburgers so his
belly and butt are really huge you're
imagining something ridiculous but i
promise you
you're not imagining something
ridiculous enough like looking at clint
is like
damn i see by the way i sit right behind
peter
and i every time i look over my shoulder
like today i looked over and he was just
like flinging ragdoll deans around
but yeah i'm doing these rag dolls and i
need to find a way to add
a directional input that calculates
based on the player's position to the
ragdoll's position and adds a force
in that direction like a vector exactly
and i don't know the math to do that and
i'm sure it's really easy
have you googled it yet so many times
really
yes yeah google's only good for so many
things it's like guitar center
of like answers yeah you know it's like
well guitar centers shut down but yeah
that was like the first thing that i
realized when i started learning more
and more about music
was like okay once you go in there and
you ask the sales employee and
and you know like 10 times the amount of
information that they know you're like
i'm gonna buy this somewhere else yep i
actually had that experience a few
months ago and they were like no
nowhere else has it i was like no i'm
getting there like come back
they're coming out of the walls like the
elevator
the door as you're trying to leave no
i'm good
the drop down ceiling panels just like
shift up and over like they start
crawling out
[Laughter]
but yeah unreal super fun i've been
loving that you've been wanting to make
a vr game right
well like i want to start getting into
like vr experiences of some sort whether
that's
uh video or games or i don't even know
what but that requires learning uh unity
sorry whoa
that requires learning uh one of these
game engines which we are now leaning
fully into learning unreal
um i'm i got a vr headset recently that
i've been obsessed with the oculus quest
ii now i've it's not my first headset
i've been in the vr for a long time
but it's only been with the new one that
i've been like my
obsession has been like reinvigorated
ren's what you'd call an early adopter
yes of technology dude i had a vr
headset in january of 2014.
wow i had the dk-1 dk1 the original the
original oculus quest dk1 the
kickstarter version it was like this
huge thing
ran at 60 frames per second no
positional tracking just rotational
and the pixels were like bb's
it's funny because uh was it christian i
think was complaining about the
resolution of the new headset i'm just
like
i don't know this is like the best
looking headset i've ever seen i
literally think it looks flawless yeah
that was when you you know the the gap
between the resolution that was
necessary to create a good image
versus the amount of resolution that you
could get and process
like effectively had not met
and it still quite hasn't it's still
getting there but like i mean
christian's not wrong it's not yet at
like
retina levels like remember like the
original iphones if you go back and look
at them you're going to look at it at me
like
oh yeah yeah the resolution is awful but
it was like the iphone 4 was the first
one that came out and they're like it's
called the retina display because it's
finally at a high enough resolution
a dpi where your eyes cannot distinguish
pixels so it just
looks crazy and vr headsets are not at
that point yet
yeah they're getting close i mean they
are going to already get iphones
probably next
gen yeah i'm just hoping they solve the
field of view
issue that's that's the same yeah i
would much rather have a higher
field of view than a higher resolution
at this point i think the quest
two had such a big jump in resolution
that i'm like all right
this is good for me like i don't desire
any more resolution
i do desire more field of view yeah you
can get those pimax headsets pmax
what is it currently i want to say it's
something like 90 degrees field of view
but
don't quote me on that okay 95. it just
feels like you're wearing goggles like
that yeah i mean
it's definitely like if you put your
your fingers in front of your head like
this
and like yeah it's like the perfect
that's kind of what it looks like
okay so like combat games like melee
games or
some more way more difficult
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
guys if you've never tried vr though i i
just bought
a i just bought a rift s right before
the new oculus came out
like during quarantine yeah and i bought
it during quarantine and i spent
it was way overpriced because you had to
get it like used
yeah like uh what do you call it when
you buy like concert tickets and you
scalp them on the streets
it was a scalped it was a skeleton
oculus yeah uh
but when i first put that on and i
played half-life alex
it blew that was that was the first time
i'd ever tried vr
so i had never tried oh my god when i
bought it at first
yeah when i bought it i i had never
tried it i bought it specifically for
half-life alex because i'm such a huge
half-life guy
and i put that on and i tried that game
and it blew
in my mind delivered that
well they consisted of playing that game
until i began
to play half life every time i got back
from work yeah when that game came out
i started playing it like i was so
obsessed with that game that like i
couldn't stop
thinking about it and like to the point
that i incorporated it into the very
next piece of content i made which was
the exponential growth video
the entire like first 45 seconds are
just like the intro to half-life alex
yeah cause it's awesome yeah that's so
good
i kept i would tell everyone about it
after that i was like you gotta try this
you haven't tried this before
it's like i was addicted to drugs yeah i
wanted to give other people
to matt i heard he bought an or a rift s
yeah and uh he's like the third owner
and no one ever changed the sweat strap
and like i'm getting kind of worried
about him and i'm just like holed up in
my apartment
there's someone i had a bone to pick
with though someone who does not like
half-life alex
what actually he thinks it's overrated
he's like eh
nico oh i thought i was gonna say that
sounds like a niko it does sound like an
eco thing but here's the other thing
he only played half the game
no he didn't get to jeff get out of here
that wasn't right of passage
yeah exactly i hated that level really
it's so
scary like it's great it's great it's
like vr is so much scarier than like a
normal 2d horror game because
you're in it yeah one of the first vr
games i played back in 2014 was a game
called dread halls it was like there
were very few games at the time
yeah and it was like a procedurally
generated like hallway
uh uh with with they had like different
like
enemies or like i think i saw like a
little girl and they had the weeping
angels if you're familiar with doctor
who basically the statues
you look at them and they're just a
statue you look away you look back and
they've moved
they're closer to you that's like a
mario thing yeah it was like it was
terrifying it was that was the first
time i ever like
literally found myself yelling and
ripping the headset off my head just
because i was so terrified
were there spiders there were not
spiders in that game okay i
there were spiders in what's what's the
uh
silent hill silent hill vr game i think
there are spiders in that game
how do you feel about that craps are
great okay
as long as they don't make great i have
a very weird relationship with spiders
there's a certain degree at which i'm
okay with them and a certain degree to
which i will
choose to run full speed into a wall
well away from them which is done on
camera yes
in season two of uh corridor was that
season two
yeah i think it's so weird to think
about seasons
still wait can we can i dig into this
phobia a little bit
i mean do you want to i want to too can
i just ask the fundamental question
have you thought about it enough to
understand where the phobia comes from
so i used to think it was because i grew
up in louisiana and they have these
banana spiders there which are literally
spiders that are this big
yeah uh huge abdomens and thoraxes and
long shiny crispy crab legs
oh yeah terrifying uh and they would
sling up these webs that were literally
like six feet wide like between trees
and i remember when i lived in louisiana
right on the other side of our like
breakfast table window there was one in
a bush there and it caught a dragonfly
and ate the whole thing like you watched
you watched it in graphic details yeah
yeah sure
yes because it took like a day yeah and
uh it was over the weekend i just
remember coming back and it'd be a
little bit more like
funneled into a little web and at the
end of it it was just like this husk
yeah this little husk the wings were
untouched but like the rest of it was
just like yeah and i was like what the
hell
yeah spiders are gnarly but i don't know
if that was the source of my phobia or
not
yeah at like a point i can look at a
spider over there and be like yeah it's
a spider no big deal
i could look at a spider maybe over
there no big deal but if i can see it
starting to move towards me that changes
everything
that is a fundamental difference if i
it's like i can observe spiders
but the moment i feel like i am in
it's so good i'm at risk of coming into
contact with a spider it changes i go
from
oh my god when i was in school one time
i was in the library and a spider
crawled out from underneath my keyboard
and i yelled and i jumped backwards and
my knees clipped the table
and i fell backwards over the chair and
then my my feet caught the table
and knocked over the computer it was one
of those imacs so the entire imac
computer fell
over oh and i had yelled like this
high-pitched yells like ah
and i flipped over and everyone in the
library we're talking like hundreds of
people in this huge
room all like what the hell who just got
shot
because i was like oh my gosh like that
was under my chair
and it was this tiny little spider that
goes crawling away and i was like
oh good so everyone sorry wow dude
i gotta ask this though is there in
relation to the size of the spider is
there like a bell curve where it's like
it gets big big big and then it gets too
big
and now it's not scary if it's like some
fantasy spider that's like
you know the size of a human then it
gets like you know you're not scared of
it in vr if it's a head crab right
i gotta look head crabs don't really
remind me of spiders they don't what
about that black one yeah i was about to
say the black one was
a very big spider sure even those ones
don't quite do it
for me i don't know i think it has to do
i think it has to do specifically with
having eight legs
and having that like uh like the
mandalorian episode with the spiders the
alien spiders kind of came close
kind of spoilers there's a mandalorian
episode of spiders big deal get over it
uh and those ones like the smaller ones
i was like
but i don't know there's like a
separation like i can watch a movie with
spiders in it and be okay
a movie like arachnophobia where the
spiders are real that's a different
story
uh mandalorian at one point the big bad
spider comes out
and i know it's inspired by original
drawings and all that
but the shape of its eyes they're googly
eyes
i'm gonna fight you on this they are
googly eyes yeah
and the moment the big bad spider comes
out it's supposed to be a big scary
moment i just
burst out laughing because it's the
funniest thing i've ever seen i was like
what the hell is this thing
yeah anything with googly eyes is funny
yeah like it doesn't matter i mean yeah
thank you star wars makers for not
making them
horrible okay so i got a little tail did
i answer your question i don't even know
god knows i think that does it googly
eyes put him on spiders and then
he said if they became big enough are
they not scary yeah yeah i don't know
shiny spiders shinier spiders are
scarier than furry spiders
on a one wheel ride a couple months ago
we saw a tarantula
which was really cool yeah uh it was
just because i i rarely see
tarantulas i think i'd only seen one
previously in the wild ever
and this was on like a neighborhood
street is a big one maybe this big just
slowly walking across the street and i
didn't bother me so maybe if you picked
it up and threw it at me i might be
charged for
[Laughter]
it had everything to do with the fact
that i wasn't touching it and i didn't
find myself at risk
at touching it it was just like doing
its own thing it was just doing
something yeah i'm down with tarantulas
actually yeah i had some friends
last night i wouldn't i kind of chased
it okay so we got yelled at chasing a
fish
a bobcat a bobcat yeah isn't there i'm
thinking of a cat
you're thinking
[Laughter]
it's a predatory cat like fish right
[Laughter]
actually i haven't told that story have
i oh i don't think so the podcast i
don't think so but
you should oh the fish story i got that
but at first i got a spider story yeah
i'll tell the fish story
okay just to finish up my thought here i
i find myself not really having a huge
amount of fear of like wild animals
um like snakes like a rattlesnake i'll
go up and like get really close to it
and it'll start like kind of like
it jumped at us a couple times it was a
baby rattlesnake i know they're more
venomous they're more venomous
they're they're weaklings dude i can't
do snakes um but yeah so last night
there was like eight of us riding along
this trail right and uh i look over and
i see these eyes in the woods
i was like whoa i immediately 180 and i
go back to it it was a bobcat and a
bobcat is not a mountain lion it's much
smaller
yeah it's about like this big it's
halfway between a house cat and like a
yeah like a yeah kind of like a like a
minx or whatever perhaps um
yeah and of course someone scurrying
away and i i wanted to i chased it a
little bit and a couple of the guys
started yelling at me calling me an
idiot for doing that
it's like it's a bobcat guys yeah yeah
yeah if it's a mountain lion that's a
different story
have you seen that video there's a
protocol for that you can't be
basically he's walking down a trail and
then just out of nowhere a
mountain lion comes right in front of
him right in front of his path
and just i think it's they saw the baby
isn't it what's that he's on like
he's on like a boardwalk no no it was
like a it was like a fire road
it was like a wide trail and i did see a
breakdown from like a
an animal professional specialist person
uh who's like he kind of wasn't doing
the right thing here
he eventually did uh but he kind of
happened in this video this he was
walking backwards along this trail as
this mountain lion continued to stalk
him
and so it was all over the news like you
know this guy gets stalked by a mountain
lion but in truth
the mountain lion was just protecting
its baby um the guy was like kind of
like not doing the right things and i i
can't remember
the details of how exactly what he was
doing wrong but there are articles you
could read them
uh and eventually he like he threw a
rock at it and it went running away
which is what he should have done a long
time ago it kept charging at him though
and then stopping so he would like
scream at it
yeah yeah and that was terrifying
because it would charge at him
and like the paws would like slap the
ground like yeah
he was like oh god like dust would go
everywhere like that
[ __ ] you up that thing kills will murder
you
and they know to go for the throat yeah
which is also terrifying
hundreds of thousands of years of
evolution with primates that's crazy
yeah saber-toothed tigers fit
their mouths fit primates
necks that's what the teeth are for oh
really the teeth are to keep your neck
from being able to slip out
oh wow really okay i could see that sure
wow
that's fascinating yeah dang okay jake
what's your spider
okay all right spider story
it was sunday uh i was getting my stuff
ready to fly out here
i have that corridor digital new era bag
sorry it's not available anymore guys
maybe next time the one hanging in the
um
uh no that's a that's a toiletry bag i i
haven't one's nice
yeah it is the first time i've ever seen
a toiletry bag and i was like i gotta
get me one of those the flip down one
that hangs yeah that's the only only way
to go
oh yeah um and so anyways uh i packed
this bag and i put my on
my on board like book and stuff in there
and i get on i get through the airport i
check my bag i go to sit down
i sit down to open up i've got like 45
minutes before my plane supposed to
board
so i go to pull out my book and i unclip
the top
remember i had packed this bag i had put
it on me
it was in the back seat of my suv where
my child was sitting close to it
and both of my children and uh
i put it on my back walked through the
airport with it
sent it through security put it back on
walked all the way to the gate sat down
unclipped it opened it up and there's
like a front flap that flips up
and then there's like accessible pockets
underneath there
brown recluse spider oh those are the
bad ones yeah
dude yes brown recluse spider just
sitting
right there and i'm like it's a brown
recluse spider
and i looked at it and it was a little
certainly alive it wasn't doing much
and i was just like okay
and i killed it uh but you just smack it
with something
uh i just killed it with my hand but
what impressive
wait with just bare hands
this part right here i was like well
i'll go for something that's calloused
it was sitting on top of a pouch so then
i just put my hand under the pouch and i
just went
oh man i just crushed it into oblivion
no thanks i think ren
is like having a whole moment over here
i'm good i'm good you're okay man i
guess i also have a spider story
um in which i overcame my fears
really and dealt with a triumph rising
from the ashes like a phoenix here we go
because sometimes even though i i hate
spiders and like they do weird things to
the chemicals going on in my brain uh i
also know
this is a problem that needs to be dealt
with so i freaking do it
um like when i discovered my driveway
was uh infested with black widows
oh yeah so my driver's like black widows
black widows
like shiny black red triangle thingy
yeah um
so my driveway uh there's you can
actually also see it in that uh
the exponential growth video when i have
like a little graph that goes that like
animates up along the ground there's
like a reflection because it's running
anyway
that concrete wall there next to the
dirt
every little slit there's like a crack
between like the like the concrete
blocks there was a web going from the
crack to the ground and a black widow
hanging out there
yeah every single crack and then out
underneath uh we have like this outdoor
patio
things will get your dogs man yeah so i
i i killed them all with the
flamethrower
play with the boring company i don't
have one of those oh okay
i think it was like do you have access
to well i have a lighter and i have
spray paint
okay makeshift like not spray paint it
was like primer or whatever
like the the the final coating you put
on lacquer clear coat okay
clear coat yeah something like that it's
more like a flame tosser and that's
that's usually what i use to kill
spiders uh and it worked really great
for that and i just went
and just burned every single one yeah
there were about 11 or 12 of them
you should spray the house and so the
very next day we had a uh
an exterminator come out and spray the
entire property yeah wow
first blacks black widows yeah that
looks like good moves yeah those things
will get gnarly
christian and i lived in a house in west
l.a and that girl
remembers your stories infested with
them
oh my god that sounds terrifying i just
remember thinking i'm glad that doesn't
happen to me
until it did so when it was happening to
me i i distinctly remember thinking man
this used to happen to jake
yeah and then my my wife was like hey
you know they make like spray for that
and i was like
really and i finally
figured out oh you can just spray the
corners of your house and they don't
create their webs there
but it's not like a one-time thing to
kill them it's like an actual spray it
prevents them
so you do it like ever i did it once a
year uh
you can do it every six months but
basically you just spray the corners
because the black widows they come out
at night and they build the webs from
about a foot down to the ground yeah
yeah i got them all the way
um the border of my house back home yeah
and so you just spray that
and then they go away does it smell like
they're dead husbands maybe
uh probably i think that's actually like
a reminder yeah
like oh man i killed my husband they
take dead eyes wow
this got morbid cool yeah it'll do that
and then i found out there's like brown
widows which i guess
aren't as poisonous i don't know much
about it as black widows
but still they they're like basically
brown and instead of having a red
uh hourglass they've got an orange
hourglass
oh but they act and they act in the
exact same way but apparently they
are in a battle right now with black
widows for like territory
what it's like two gangs very serious
it's literally like gang wars for
spiders
yeah because black widows i guess
there's some
they're at some disadvantage like
naturally in la where like the brown
widows have the upper hand right now
yeah that's hilarious yeah it's really
funny
so the brown widows are there's a whole
situation i don't know
i think the l.a gang unit's on yeah yeah
the spider cobby
i didn't know tarantulas were native to
california i know they're native to
texas now
there's a bunch of animals that'll kill
you in texas a bunch of insects which i
realized
only after moving out there there's
there's tarantula tarantulas can't kill
you but
they're just kind of terrifying in
general yeah then there's uh
uh what are those things called rattler
snakes
um rattlers yeah yeah i mean i
texas is in the south now so i know i'm
picking up rattlers
this is way cooler than that they have
their own word for it
texas texas reminds me of like uh united
states australia
it was funny moving over there like i'm
starting to be able to tell the
difference between like a texas accent a
louisiana accent a georgia accent
a carolina accent like all of those they
all sound different yeah
it's my louisiana accent yeah i miss it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
think definitely
oh yeah that's right yeah but it's been
a very long time so i don't have one at
all
you can't bring it back for us no not
today i gotta practice
oh man we'll come back next time and
next week
yeah so anyway there's a bunch of
there's a bunch of insects that'll kill
you there's uh
there's uh centipedes okay really
normally centipedes aren't
yeah they're not that big of a deal
until you get to the big ones
oh boy and there's there's ones that are
like this big oh yeah
red gnarly and they bite and if you if
they bite a kid like you gotta
take the kid in because like it's like
poisonous yeah it's like worse it's like
10 times a bee sting
apparently yeah they're not they're not
like deadly but they're like
really really bad and then there's brown
recluse spiders obviously
yeah brown recluses freaked me out yeah
and those things
they naturally run into your bed yeah
they go into your house that's the worst
thing is like
they go into your house i hope my wife
doesn't listen to this podcast because
when i found that brown recluse on my
backpack
i casually texted her and i was like oh
also while i'm gone
if you want to have the guys come by and
spray the house feel free
just you know at your leisure everywhere
spray every corner of the house
please god jesus christ spray everything
i spray the kids
[Laughter]
dude my wife found a spider in our bed a
few days ago like friday
yeah um because i was playing pop one
with both uh nico and dee
and we're when we play together we we do
really well and so we're having a good
time
and i hear this screech from the other
room and i'm like uh oh i know what
that meant yeah and i was like what's up
you good
she's like yep all good i was like
no it's not yeah and so she killed it
and left this big wet stain on
the covers like under the covers on the
sheets
and so i had to like yeah i had to like
mute my
microphone from the game so they're like
asking me like
tactical information i'm like babe
where's the spider did you get it
was it what kind of spider was it i
don't know i didn't ask okay apparently
it was like penny size maybe a little
larger
not bad but it left a big wet stain oh
juices are the grossest juices
i don't know more power to you if you
can do it but i can't imagine like
eating
bugs like as that's what we're all going
to be eating in the future man
yeah those are going to be alive well
after everything else well after us
so yeah it's going to be a sustainable
foods that's just the idea of like
yeah blind kelly is the only sir we'll
get a ground up
in mexican culture they eat like
crickets and yeah right yeah
i've tried them when i drink crickets in
front of me one time and i was
yeah like off the ground like hank no
they're like dried and fried yeah
like coated in cheddar and stuff but at
that point they're just like chest
shells
you know yeah yeah i'm not gonna be an
ecto skeleton
yeah pretty much that's that's what
you're getting is if i had to i would
first take chris
yeah um so anyway should we talk about
the guard
oh yes we should we should talk about
the guard i wonder if
oh yeah i still got a gar scarf oh you
got a garcia scarf yeah
first off can you describe what a gar is
uh so an alligator gar
is a uh like a
couple million year old like fish
freshwater fish
um and uh it's this gnarly looking thing
and it's got
a snout that looks like an alligator and
it's got teeth
right and it's basically other than that
it looks like a muskie or like a
northern pike it's like a long
a a large long fish and this one
that i encountered wasn't that big
because it was in a tank but they can
get
huge is it a relative of a shark uh
i mean they're all relatives i don't
know how long ago you got to go in the
ecosystem but and is this a cat or a
fish
this is a cat okay yeah it's a it's a
cat with a long snout no
an aquatic cat so yeah it uh so anyway
we were filming a commercial at bass pro
shop
out in texas yep out in texas and uh
they've got all the
marine wildlife in the tank there you
know uh and
uh we're looking at it and we were on
production and this was like night three
maybe it was night four i don't remember
it was later into the production
yeah um and uh we were in a hold
um on like lighting or something and uh
so i'm the first ad on the set and it's
my job to like not
[ __ ] around but and for some a little
bit more context you know while we were
filming
and during the whole production jake was
like super professional and like
killing it okay a.d wise like he was
just like great he was
he's really great he's really just a
great a.d thanks uh
so but i for like 10 seconds i wasn't
he had a moment
uh we're looking at these fish how big
is this tank
that the fish are in large tank like a
tank like twice the size of this room
whoa yeah um and they're swimming around
in there
and there's an alligator gar that's like
about three feet long
like maybe about the length of this
guitar maybe a little longer this is a
gear so it wasn't that big it was a baby
for in terms of like the way that
alligator guards get
and uh the gaffer had a laser pointer
because that's what he used to tell
the the uh electricians and the grips
like where to put the lights
so he's got this green laser pointer and
he points it into the fish tank
and all the fish just immediately go
start following the following the laser
around
the laser on the glass shot through the
glass and into the tank and then it
refracted through the water and the fish
were following the laser
beam like the beam itself versus like a
point yeah the beam itself
and the point so that you had fish that
were probably like looking at
like the beams coming this way fish
looking here fish looking there yeah the
fish
exactly and so was everyone congregating
on like a spot yeah
exactly okay now some of them were
congregating like where it went through
the glass somewhere it hit the wall
behind it and some on the beam itself
but the point is that they noticed it
they noticed it
very well you're like wow and we all
we did that human you know is advanced
and like technological and
wise as we think we are we're just apes
and as soon as that laser went into the
glass we were
all the humans sat down and we're like
oh something's interesting here
have you noticed this yeah
like you know examining the possible
prey sort of thing
and we were like okay oh and then i got
and then i noticed this alligator car
and brad started raising the laser beam
up towards the top of the water and this
alligator car just kind of floated up
and i was right next to the tank
and kurt one of these one of this one of
this he's
he's a marine vet and he's like sitting
behind me and he was on production and
he's like
hey jake i bet you bet you 10 bucks you
can't stick your hand in there and grab
that guard by the nose
and i was like you know i bet i could
instead of thinking i believe instead of
thinking screw you kurt
i i thought for some reason i was just
like actually i probably could because i
thought it was so
mesmerized by the beam and this is where
a million years of fish evolution
beats 50 or 100 000 years of human
evolution every single time
it's like nah dude i already saw you
like i'm focused on the beam but you
don't even know
and i'm like and i reached my hand it
was about
two inches from the surface of the water
and so i'm standing on the ledge and
there's the ledges the glass ledge is
right here and the guards literally
right here
okay and so i reach my hand up like this
and then i just go and i try to grab it
on the nose
and like literally as i did that it was
sitting right here
and it here's what it did with his jaw
open
hand down clasp and then i
wrapped my thumb around the bottom of
his jaw
and now we're in like a death bind and
and i can feel as soon as he bit me i
was like [ __ ] you know
and i could feel that he had my hand but
i was like okay
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna fight with
him i'm not gonna fling him out yeah i'm
not gonna fling him because then he's
just gonna rip his teeth across my hand
so then i i pulled i just pulled him out
of the water
and he and he came out of the water and
he was like
and when he came out of the water he
kind of let go but as he let go he kind
of
dragged his hand his mouth across my
hand and i had this
gar scar yeah
unfortunately it was only skin deep and
there was only just a little blood and
there was a set medic
and now to offer a bit of perspective on
this from our side
uh picture this whole fish tank as like
a theater
wait is he gonna do it is he gonna is he
gonna grab the guard
he's gonna grab the guard he reaches and
[Laughter]
he just looks up for a second and then
just blood
and drip loss yeah and then applause
naturally the curtain's closed
embarrassed applause um and then the set
medic came over and patched me up
yeah and that was that but uh if you
notice on the
uh black rifle commercial which they'll
it'll be on their
uh youtube channel if you watch that
video the damages for the store
one of the one of the line items for the
damages for the store i think you put
this
i've never been more proud of the
effects shot than it is
yeah yeah that's that's my magnum opus
right yeah so he's putting that in
so wow yeah needless to say i felt like
a huge [ __ ]
but uh i i don't know what made me think
that
this thing wouldn't have a faster
reaction time in its environment that
it's been living in for a million years
probably a lot longer than we're talking
like probably hundreds of millions of
years
yeah it was like fish of that type are
very very ancient
yeah so i just i don't know why i
thought that i was going to beat it at
its own game but
i did and i paid for it well fortunately
it was small because if it was a
i when it was a real one i wouldn't have
reached for it but if it was a real one
those things can bite your hand
dude imagine if you lost your hand
that'd be awful
you come back with a hook
so here's a a fact that may or may not
blow your mind
sharks are older than trees
and i read this on twitter from phil uh
scifil on twitter
um science youtube my mind it took me so
like i
and then i read it again and i thought
about it and i read it a third time
and then i finally feel like i started
comprehending the magnitude of
what that statement meant like literally
sharks have been around
longer than plant life that's how old
sharks are well like just like
the idea of like a predatory fish like
that with like really intense jaws and
teeth
yeah is that interesting like the
surface of the earth
was like it was underdeveloped or it was
maybe the climate was too
hot or even rather there wasn't actual
like land well life
developed in the ocean first because
that's inhabitable yeah so it was
fully an ocean planet right for some
reason i always thought that plants
developed first i guess
because they're less comfortable i can't
remember my history
but there was pangaea yeah and then
and everybody was chill and everyone was
chilling the contest
spread apart but it wasn't so happy lied
and pangaea split apart yeah
you're saying oh that's that's good
that's a good reference you're saying
that like
even there were land masses but they
were barren
land masses yes yes okay well in the
beginning
yeah in the in the i don't know for how
long and i don't know to what extent
uh plant life did become a thing on the
surface
but trees are a very specific subset of
plant life yeah
they didn't come around until later
interesting they were around when the
dinosaurs were around
yes
exactly which is crazy because that was
65 million years ago to like 150 million
years and that was just the most recent
uh cataclysm there were like three
others i think before that
like hundreds of millions how old do
they think the earth is like 400 million
4.7 billion years 4.7 billion
yes oh my god wow that's really wild
wait is 4.7 or 4.3
either way i think the moon might be 4.3
sounds
i don't know what i'm doing you know
what's weird is whenever i think of this
guy
i don't mean to i don't mean to take
this away from you but whenever i think
of a billion now
i think of that the billion video i
think of
the tom oh the other one the other
billion video
the one where the oh tom scott's billion
videos we actually like
rode down the street when i think of the
scale of a billion i mean
that video was brilliant and great too
it was a very different kind of video
yeah
and he mentions it in that video it's
like this is a very different
kind this is a different way to kind of
help you understand a billion because
yeah
it still comes down to the fact that our
brains are literally incapable
of understanding a billion we are but
after that and after your video i do
kind of understand it now so when you
say 4.3 billion
yeah i understand how much more that is
than 400 million
it's not even like comp it's barely
comprehensibly
it sounds 400 million 4 billion what's
the difference
yeah brother hold on
so we've got a long way to go yeah yeah
yeah so that's hard i i was dealing a
lot with billions today
i was researching a new scale video uh
talking about how much data
is used by humanity and storage spaces
and stuff like that
yeah i'm in the early stages so i don't
want to say too much more than that but
yeah so if one met a zero and they hit
it off
they'd
like like just some of the stuff that i
was reading is like so zettabyte for
instance is
is very big um it's bigger than a
petabyte bigger than an exabyte
uh i don't even know what those are
exactly yeah so a petabyte i know
petabyte is big is a thousand times
a terabyte yeah and you know we all know
what terabytes are that's kind of like
the upper echelon of like
storage space right now like our server
is like 150 terabytes or something like
that
yeah um i thought we had a petabyte of
something but maybe not
no we do not oh man that would be the
flex
that would be the ultimate place
i mean we could get there we could and
i'm sure
we'll work our way up maybe linus tech
tips has a petabyte at this point maybe
couple petabytes i don't know probably
but uh an exabyte is a thousand
petabytes and a zettabyte is a thousand
exabytes
and humanity is producing
something on the order of like
there's a couple different ways it's
like we have there is like
five or six pet zettabytes of storage
currently
but something like we consume copy or
create
uh 60 zettabytes of data
in 2020. so how many gigabytes yeah so
that's what i'm saying
a zettabyte is a billion terabytes
just wow those so it yeah and so it goes
back to a billion so it's like all right
if i'm trying to
show a a billion terabytes
that still doesn't work because we can't
comprehend a billion
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy you need
to just
drive as long as it takes we're just
going to upload a 10 hour video of me
driving to oregon this
is one step if this one step is a
gigabyte
let me show you how far you have to go
to get to a zettabyte
yeah just let your tesla do it by itself
like just send it off cuts to a shop
i'll see you tomorrow you cut to that
shot of christopher reeves going around
them
that's a good idea for man yeah and then
where he turns back time yeah but only
this time we reverse that footage
yeah and then he's going forward
what do you think's going to happen do
you think it's just going to kind of
like fringe off
fringe what do you mean yeah like do you
think like we'll lose it you know
lose what the all that data data
floating right there's obviously
important data
all the urls and where they're gonna go
and then there's unimportant data
you know like v like
v2 for ren
export 12 underscore final yeah
what happens to all of those well i mean
think about every single thing that
occurs
is data like every time you uh send a
text message that's data every time you
walk down the street
yeah your phone is you know pinging uh
cells
you know cell towers just getting gps
data like new data is being created
literally
anytime you even barely think yeah and
so that's going somewhere
a lot of the time this data is like
unneeded so it gets written over
um because it's you know whatever
but the thing is that storage is
increasing
exponentially as well so we're just able
to just continue storing more and more
information
it's like the wild west yeah like yeah
how far does that country go
but like it's increasingly exciting
they're saying that like
we're expecting consuming something like
250 zettabytes in just five years
is that in counting is that accounting
for deletion
i think so so i don't think like i think
that's like a revenue as opposed to like
a net
type okay deal you know there is a
saying or rather a profit table
this is a gross people yeah i think it's
more of like a gross like this much was
created and it's not being subtracted
everything that was deleted okay
i think again i just started research
today
people say you can't truly delete
anything off the internet is that true
or is it well kind of true really delete
anything
ever right you you can only replace
things like it's still
some form of it is on your hard drive so
like yes when you delete something on
your hard drive
basically it just gets indexed as being
able to be overwritten
right that's why like if you delete
something it's not actually there
you can still like bring it back you can
recover it
and to actually delete something if you
want to actually permanently delete it
so that it cannot be recovered
all of those actual like atoms or
whatever that like the ones and zeros
are
being sourced to they have to be
scrambled entirely so that it's just
nonsense information yeah but you could
uh in theory
unscramble that and still like i mean if
you're like
in like a really really powerful like
ai or a quantum computer maybe you
cannot scramble eggs that's what they
say
hey i never heard that one that's a good
thing it is a good one that is a good
yeah i got a trademark you cannot you
can bake a cake put them in a flower
and eat them i learned this
oh you do i honestly do nice yeah
my burritos stay nice and they do isn't
that a good technique talking about
cakes you're talking about burritos
but no were you saying because you're
you're talking about that was an
important thing
in engineering yeah it's material
property uh i think it goes along with
like
again it's been so long since i was in
engineering school i don't remember
anything from it
but it's like a material property has
there are some times
when it has like a one directional like
transformation
like a cake or an egg like you apply
heat to it it changes you can never undo
that
whereas like a metal you can harden it
and then you can melt it you can harden
it again you can melt it again yeah
the other episodes right here on
corridor cast you can find it on our
website quarterdigital.com or on
youtube.com
cordorcast or anywhere podcasts are
found thanks for listening guys
this is a fun one in the next one we're
going to figure out what comes after
a zettabyte whoa what does come after
unscramble that data boys i'm hungry
all right i'm going to play us out sweet
thanks for listening everyone
thank you i just made everyone listening
uh clear their own throats what comes
after a zettabyte
i don't know i don't know i
[Music]
we gotta work on our singing bye it's
improv
you gotta bite